TREY: WELCOME BACK TO SUNDAY
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN
AMERICA."
>> A YEAR AGO DARREL BROOKS
DROVE A CAR THROUGH A
CHRISTMAS PARADE IN
WISCONSIN.
6 PEOPLE KILLED DOZENS
INJURED.
BROOKS A CAREER CRIMINAL ON
ANOTHER CRIME SPREE, HE IS
NOW IN COURT, CONTINUES TO
VICTIMIZE INNOCENT PEOPLE
AND TRYING TO MAKE A MOCKERY
OF OUR LEGAL SYSTEM.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE FACTS
OR THE LAW, POUND THE TABLE.
BROOKS IS POUNDING THE
TABLE.
>> I DON'T CARE -- YOU ARE
NOT BY BEING FAIR,
YOU ARE BEING BIASED.
>> JUDGE, DO YOU HOLD FULL
JUDICIAL POWER OF THE STATE.
>> TAKE JURY OUT.
>> YOU CAN TESTIFY IF THE
STATE OF WISCONSIN IS A
LIVING HUMAN BEING.
>> ONE OF THE JURORS FLIPPED
ME OFF COMING IN.
>> I'M NOT CONSENT --
LISTENING TO ANYTHING YOU
SAY.
>> I'M NOT ASKING YOU
QUESTIONS.
TREY: HE IS REPRESENTING
HIMSELF AND PROVING WHY THAT
IS SUCH A TERRIBLE IDEA.
BROOKS IS NOT A LAWYER, BUT
A THUG.
A THUG WITH NOTHING TO LOSE.
TO THE VICTIMS RELIVING THE
NIGHTMARE TO THOSE WHO LOST
LOVED ONE TO THOSE BERATED
IN COURT DO, NOT LOSE HOPE.
BROOKS WILL BE CONVICTED.
HE WILL BE LEAD AWAY FROM
THE COURTROOM IN HANDCUFFS
AND LEG IRONS.
JOINING US NOW CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY FORMER
HOMICIDE DETECTIVE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TED WILLIAMS.
IT IS SO NICE TO HAVE YOU.
UNDERSTAND THAT HIS CONDUCT
FRUSTRATES OUR VIEWERS.
I HAVE GOTTEN A LOT OF TEXT
AND E-MAILS FROM PEOPLE VERY
FRUSTRATED.
HE REPRESENTS HIMSELF, IF
THE JUDGE WERE TO KICK HIM
OUT OF COURTROOM THERE IS NO
LAWYER PRESENTS.
IS THAT KNOW AN ISSUE
ON APPEAL, THE JUDGE IS IN A
TOUGH SPOT.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
THE JUDGE IS IN A TOUGH
SPOT, SHE IS TRYING
TO MAINTAIN ORDER IN HER
COURTROOM AND YET GIVE THIS
MAN A FAIR TRIAL.
THE THING ABOUT IT, YOU KNOW
IT, I HAVE BEEN HERE LONG
BEFORE, THAT AND I HAVE GONE
AGAINST PRO SE LITIGANTS
THEY ARE SOME WORSE TO
ADVOCATE AGAINST.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE, THAT
NOT ONLY SHOULD THIS MAN BE
ON TRIAL.
BUT THE SYSTEM IN WAUKESHA
SHOULD BE ON TRIAL.
THE QUESTION THAT
VIEWERS SHOULD ASK IS WHY IS
THIS MAN NO COURT, HE IS IN
COURT BECAUSE TWO WEEKS
BEFORE HE MOWED DOWN 6
PEOPLE AND KILLED THEM, TWO
WEEKS BEFORE THAT, HE MOWED
DOWN HIS GIRLFRIEND.
AND HE WAS LET OUT ON A
$1,000 CASH BOND THIS IS
WHAT THEY THOUGHT.
AND THEN WHEN THEY WENT TO
THE D.A. AND PRESENTED THIS
AFTER HE KILLED 6 PEOPLE,
ALL OF THE D.A. COULD SAY,
WELL THIS WAS HUMAN ERROR.
HUMAN ERROR MY BUTT.
6 PEOPLE ARE DEAD.
AND THIS CLOWN, IS ON TRIAL,
REPRESENTING HIMSELF, AND
YOU HAVE SAID AND I AGREE,
IF THE JURY IS OUT OVER 30
MINUTES I'M GO STOCK
SURPRISED.
THIS -- GOING TO BE
SURPRISED THIS MAN WILL BE
FOUND GUILTY.
TREY: YOU RAISED AN
INTERESTING POINT, I'M BEEN
STUNNED AT NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO CONTACTED ME, SAYING HE
MUST BE INCOMPETENT AND
INSANE, NO, HE IS A TYPICAL
DEFENDANT, WE SEE THIS ALL
OF THE TIME BUT NOT ON
TELEVISION, IS THERE ANY
DANGER A JURY WILL SAY,
WELL, YOU KNOW, I KNOW HE
DID IT, BUT HE DIDN'T HAVE A
LAWYER.
JURIES MAY NOT KNOW WHY HE
DOESN'T HAVE A LAWYER, HE
CHOSE NOT TO HAVE ONE.
IS THERE ANY DANGER A JURY
MISINTERPRET THIS AND TO
SOMETHING CRAZY?
>> NOW IN THIS CASE, I DO
NOT SEE THAT.
I SEE THIS MAN GOING DOWN
AND BEING CONVICTED.
THE EVIDENCE IS OVERWHELMING
IN THIS CASE.
I CAN TELL YOU, I HESITATE
JUST SLIGHTLY BECAUSE I FELT
THE PARKLAND SHOOTER IN
FLORIDA WAS GETTING THE
DEATH PENALTY.
THE SAD PROBLEM HERE IN
WISCONSIN, THEY DON'T HAVE
THE DEATH PENALTY.
IF THEY HAD THE DEATH
PENALTY, I THINK HE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE LOOKING AT THAT
DEATH PENALTY UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THIS CASE.
HE TOOK THAT VEHICLE, HE
INTENTIONALLY RAN INTO THE
CROWD.
AND HE KILLED THOSE PEOPLE.
AND WE CAN'T GET AROUND
THAT, HE CAN'T GET AROUND IT
I DON'T THINK THAT ANY JURY
AND JURY IN WAUKESHA WILL
LET HIM GET AROUND IT.
THE MAIN THING FOR THE JUDGE
TO DO IS TO GIVE HIM A FAIR
TRIAL, SO ON APPEAL SHE WILL
NOT BE REVERSED.
TREY: YOU KNOW WHAT, TED, I
COULD NOT AGREE WITH YOU
MORE.
WE SHOULD NEVER BE WATCHING
THIS SPECTACLE HE NEVER
SHOULD HAVE BEEN OUT OF JAIL
TO DO THIS AT A CHRISTMAS
PARADE, HE IS A LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD WINNER IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM, AND
HOW IN THE WORLD HE GOT OUT
IN WISCONSIN, YOU WILL HAVE
TO COME BACK ON ANOTHER TIME
AND WE COULD SORT THAT OUT.
UNTIL THEN, I WISH I HAD
BEEN ABLE TO PROSECUTE SOME
OF YOUR CASES OR TRY A FEW
BESIDE YOU, COME BACK AND
SEE US SOMETIMES.